all right let's move on to the next
story which is uh about my crazy
california now the funny thing here of
course is that i
as people know i'm in los angeles uh liz
you
fled california alex you told me right
before you started you're you're coming
back
so first off are you nuts before i even
get to the story
i don't know i'm in love is the issue no
i've gotta i'm following my wife
out there but it's amazing because i'm
sure the u-haul i'll be going in one
direction seeing all the
trucks going in the other direction
towards the same parts of the country
no it's nuts but i you know i've always
lived this way i'm from l.a i've been in
dc for eight years and i went to
berkeley so
i've always enjoyed kind of being inside
the belly of the beast and
you know heading back to garcetti's la
and newsomes california i'm sure it's
going to fit the breitbart
editor-in-chief's persona
perfectly that's funny you're literally
the one guy who's going to replenish the
u-haul stock in california as
everybody's moving them across the
country so the story that i want to
cover we're going to show the tweet
right now
gavin newsom our insane evil disney
cartoon character of a governor who is
being recalled
well he is launching a 116.5
million dollar giveaway for vaccinated
californians exclamation point
15 million in cash prizes for 10 winners
selected
on june 15th 50k for winners on june
uh fourth and june 11th and if you're
already vaccinated you're entered
not vaccinated next two million that get
fully vaccinated can also get a 50
card let's do this california
vax for the win uh so my question
to you first liz since you did flee
california
is this idiocracy are we actually in
idiocracy right now where
if you get vaccinated you get a 50 card
and a lottery ticket i mean is that
is that why you fled no it isn't in fact
i will be honest here and i have a
little buyer's remorse about leaving
california because california is
paradise the liberal policies are insane
but we shouldn't actually write off
california and just leave we should
fight for it
we didn't leave california just because
of the liberal policies we left for job
reasons um and i do miss it and i hope
that people stay and fight because it is
a lovely
a lovely lovely state and it's worth
fighting for that's the first thing
the second thing is how is it even legal
and i've been doing research on this how
is it
even legal for the government to pay
people to take an experimental vaccine
i i just am fundamentally against the
idea of a government and politicians
trying to encourage people to take
medical treatments that haven't really
been studied
you can offer it and that's great but
beyond that it's simply none of your
business and it shows the disconnect
between the elites i think and the
american people
that if the american people wanted to
get vaccinated they would if they
believed
politicians rhetoric on covet 19 then
that then that's fine
but that you can see this disconnect
because you shouldn't have to pay people
to do this
if they truly believe it's necessary
kevin is that the key point that
the professional class has just ruined
themselves to the point
that if we're in the worst pandemic in
modern times they can't even get people
to take the vaccine without giving them
a 50
gift card yeah and i think we've reached
the point where people who
don't have the vaccine are looking at
everyone who does saying
what's the big push to get me to get it
everyone has had a chance there's no
longer being denied to anyone
if you're scared of it you have it and
you're safe
from me if you're that scared of me why
do you care anymore if i get it because
we're at that point where anyone could
have gotten it so there's no excuse for
someone
to be going around terrified of
unvaccinated people
because they can go get the vaccine
themselves and they can persuade
themselves or remove themselves of any
fear they might have
the other really interesting part of
this that tweet he says
if you have the vaccine you've already
been entered
when i hear that i start thinking well
wait a second how
i thought you guys weren't tracking on
some big database of everyone who's got
the vaccine
how did you enter everyone into this if
they got the vaccine i think
a lot of people overlook that part i
want to talk more about that yeah that's
a great point actually we're told that
if you show an id
to go vote somehow that's racist but
they're going to track you
if you've taken the vaccine and then
they might give you some cash
marlo you're going to get in on this you
want some of that new some money
okay first of all if the vaccine is so
amazing
why is joe biden still wearing his mask
alone outside
after he got it that's very bad vaccine
messaging
takes the mask off outdoors it's a it's
it's a fair point but jill's doing it
too and i'm told she's the best doctor
who's ever existed
so that's that's a big deal uh but in
all honesty the thing that offends me
the most about this
is that this is taxpayer money uh what
right does gavin newsom have mr french
laundry guy
uh mr white truffle guy what does he
have to do with
the taxpayers money and he's saying he's
going to
pay random people because they're
getting injected with the fda's
not approved yet serum i mean it's
unbelievable even if you love the
vaccine
the thought that this is where taxpayer
money is going at all
and who's fence sitting on the vaccine
anyway don't we have enough information
to make up our mind
it's so infantilizing but that's what
the california super state does
so liz because you left and as you said
it was for for work purposes
and yeah and you miss california i mean
i see this stuff and i'm with alex i'm
just like
because every day now now that newsome
knows he's getting recalled every day
he's got a new government program
and 4 billion for this and 87 trillion
for this and he's just making you know
they all make up
numbers and it's a one-party state and
all of that stuff but do you honestly
think it could be turned around like
when you see someone like me that's
trying to stay and fight
you don't think i'm completely insane
well i didn't say i didn't think you
were completely insane dave let's not
conflate the two
things i think you better hold on to
your wallet
is what i think you better do until
newsome is recalled because he's just
trying to empty that he's trying to dip
his hands
into your wallet and take everything
that's uh in there i i do actually
believe that there's hope even for
liberal states i actually don't
subscribe to the viewpoint
that deep blue states or deep red states
stay that color if you look at the
electoral history of our country swing
states constantly change california used
to be republican
now it's democrat you know texas might
turn blue god forbid
they might it might turn blue there's a
ton of examples of states that were once
read and have turned blue and were once
blue and have turned red so it can
always be saved you just have to find
out what's important to people
how government officials are preventing
what's important from people from taking
place
and then tell the people that the
government officials are doing that and
that changes people's minds when they're
impacted personally
dave can i ask dc right now yeah go
ahead alex
yeah yeah dave dave what what party are
you going to declare for when you jump
in here
the governor's race you know i have had
so many people in the last couple weeks
ask me and offer me money to run like
they'll back me
and the whole thing and it's like the
problem is even if i was crazy enough to
do it
even if i was just like yes i will
actually do it it's
such a deeply corrupt one-party state
that even if even if i felt i could get
enough votes and actually i do think
there are enough blue people here who
have been mugged by reality and now
we're basically
what i would say are kind of new school
conservatives which i would include all
of us
in i just think the state is just so
deeply corrupt in brooklyn but by the
way rick grinnell who i'm sure you guys
all know
rick is working on fixing some of the
the voter uh
lists here so but you know i don't know
i don't know i tried to put pressure on
him too the other day i texted him and i
was like are you going to tell me when
you're going to announce when is that
going to be
when is it going to be i would say dave
one i spoke one time
i don't want to say too much go ahead
dave one point for you maybe
you say everyone's offering money to
help the campaign maybe just say i'm
gonna launch an exploratory committee uh
yes
maybe get some of the money in there and
then wink wink and then decide
afterwards maybe not to run
i could just take that money and put a
down payment on a house in florida it's
not a bad idea phillips i like it but
can you talk about because you
you were a dc guy right and you just
moved now to tennessee because obviously
the daily wire fled
los angeles and they're in tennessee can
you talk a little bit about just
culturally what it's been like i was in
i saw you in tennessee a couple weeks
ago in nashville
and it felt so profoundly different to
me
to be going from a blue state to a red
state
it's the first place i think that a lot
of us have lived where
it doesn't feel like it's the we're
swimming upstream against the culture it
actually feels like the culture is going
with us
the governor of tennessee just passed a
bill banning critical race theory in
schools they just passed constitutional
carry
they just said you can't require vaccine
passports there are all these things
that are happening where i'm actually
looking at the local government saying
wait a second
that's a positive thing i like that and
i think there are going to be more and
more people that are attracted to that
tennessee is having a boom right now
people coming here because there's no
state income tax
there's so fewer regulations for people
looking to start businesses real
estate's actually affordable
and i do think that there is going to be
an exodus from the big cities we're
already seeing it but
not not to put my boomer hat on but
really truly
cities i think are we're going to look
back at this period of american history
where all these people just crammed into
big cities and
people are going to laugh there because
cities are only going to get worse
because they're only going to continue
to be run by democrats until people wake
up
and i think what's happening in
tennessee it's kind of an example where
people are flooding here by the
thousands every single week because of
the freedom and offers
and again cities i think are the the
kind of way of the past
sorry for anyone living in a big city to
liz's point though you know what happens
is the democrats come in they wreck all
of these cities i mean portland seattle
san francisco los angeles you guys know
all of it and then what happens
conservatives come in and fix it i mean
giuliani fixed a disaster in new york
city
by dinkins who was a progressive and now
the progressives de blasio are ruining
it again